[Musique]
depuis plus de 40 ans il explore le
monde et nous fait découvrir les
contrées les plus reculées de la planète
c'est d'abord en tant que médecin qu'il
a commencé ses expéditions parce que
c'est d'abord sous l'aspect médical
qu'il a voulu observer l'humain dans des
conditions extrêmes et tout ça là on est
partout surtout là où le corps est mis à
rude épreuve tenez en 1986 il est le
premier homme à atteindre le pôle nord
en se dirigeant seulement grâce au
soleil mais au delà de l' expertise
scientifique et technique dont il est
doté évidemment il faut quand même un
sacré courage pour entreprendre des
explorations aussi folle est il
d'ailleurs un peu fou on va lui poser la
question bienvenue dans un monde un
regard bienvenue jean louis etienne et
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes l'auteur d'explorateurs
d'océan est ce que vous êtes un peu fou
après du tout pas du tout on s'en fout
il ya toujours de la raison dans les
expéditions il ya bien sûr quelque chose
qui ne paraît pas raisonnable au commun
des mortels mais ça fait partie de mon
chemin que j'ai jeu masqué m'intéresse
comble quand il ya une zone difficile
d'accès
mettre en place les moyens qu'il faut
pour y aller éventuellement entraîner
une population de scientifiques qui
s'intéressent à ce secteur là mais c'est
c'est très structurant dans les dalles
pas les indes à 138,6 d'accord mais vous
l'avez dit elle commun des mortels et
pierre grand léjon que je veux qu'ils
paraissent un peu fou pour nous simples
oui ça peut paraître fou effectivement
mais sincèrement ça demande une
préparation
bon il ya eu les espérons que vous
évoquez le pôle nord en 86 solitaires au
pôle nord c'était avant le gps savoir
avant un téléphone donc c'est une
immersion intense quoi il y avait une
part de folie en même temps une ultra
raison de manière à pouvoir résister à
cet engagement qui était démesurée et
après je suis un travail de deux chefs
d'entreprise d'expéditions lointaines
voyez pas une expédition c'est une
entreprise quand vous emmener des gens
il faut structurer tout ça quoi et c'est
pas fou du tout c'est très organisés
j'imagine et méthodique c'est un travail
incroyable de plusieurs année ben c'est
une expédition c'est un peu comme si
jamais une table de mixage voyez-le
table de mixage ou en offert toute
avancée en même temps et ça va de la
construction que l'on doit faire la
recherche de financement l'aspect
juridique aspects financiers l'équipe
gérer une équipe etc et c'est ce qu'il
faut faire avancer conjointement des
fois ça dure deux trois ans la prochaine
ça fait dix ans que je travaille dessus
donc c'est vraiment un engagement sur la
durée pour réduire le risque au maximum
j'imagine réduire le risque et puis les
choses sont pas tout le temps facile
là je viens de traverser ce que j'ai
appelé un rodéo politico administratives
pour arriver
à construire le prochain projet je vous
en parlerai bien sûr et donc il ya des
choses qui me dépassent l'administratif
moi je suis complètement dépassé par le
côté administratif tellement on invente
des choses complexes pour arriver à en
france en particulier oh je travaille
surtout en france oui ce donc donc celle
administratif français qui est qui
l'administration française qui est un
problème c'est pas l'administration qui
est un problème c'est une fréquente et
l'administration que ça pose des
problèmes alors on va revenir un peu sur
votre parcours personnel ce qui a priori
rien sur le papier ne vous prédestinait
à l'exploration comment le fils de
tailleur d'habits je ne me trompe pas
envie al castres qui fait du rugby on
arrive à l'aventuré extrême comment
d'abord je n'avais pas les notes pour
entrer en sixième voyez donc j'ai fait
le certificat d'études qui était un
diplôme minimale et après qu'on faisait
une formation professionnelle on la
laisse au collège technique il y avait
un concours alors soual été élu pour le
collège technique soin d'aller en
formation professionnelle un
apprentissage donc j'étais au collège
technique moi je voulais faire menuisier
j'ai toujours aimé le bois même encore
j'aime travailler le bois et au collège
technique de mazamet dans le tarn
quand je me présente n'y avait plus de
places en menuiserie donc aux mamies
ajusteur sur métaux et donc j'ai fait
ainsi appelé de tourneur fraiseur je
suis l'ambassadeur de la formation
professionnelle voyagé j'ai connu les
veilles les de l'intérêt pour
l'apprentissage pour la à travers cette
formation professionnelle en faisait
j'avais 13 ans et demi en avait 14
heures par semaine en faisait 16 heures
d'atelier de la technologie de
construction technologie des matériaux
j'ai découvert les mathématiques après
le ca paix la pose de maths madame pujol
inoubliable pour moi elle dit ce garçon
il faudrait l'orienter vers le bac et
donc je suis rentré en seconde d'un bac
technique qui venait d'être d'être créée
si vous voulez et le bac c'était quelque
chose qui n'avait pas imaginé qu est ce
que je vais faire avec le bayer et j'ai
fait médecine j'ai eu j'ai une bourse et
donc je me suis lancé dans des études de
médecine je reste un peu là dessus parce
que c'est fort ce que vous dites pour
les jeunes qui nous écoutent où les
parents des jeunes communistes vous dit
que vous n'aviez pas les notes pour
rentrer ensemble mais qu'on vous
orienter vers une formation
professionnelle qui a eu du sens pour
vous mais naturellement envoyé dans le
dos ne passe pas très loin du sénat
d'ailleurs dans le quartier il ya un
lycée professionnel et je passais la
à midi les élèves sortent et il y en a
un qui dit à l'autre et d'un quoi toi il
lui répond je suis en pâtisserie
c'est génial et dans le c'est
génial vous comprenez il avait mis la
machine en route parce qu'un enfant qui
a 13 ans qui en troisième qu'il trouve
pas sa place dans le cursus scolaire il
a quand même de l'énergie c'est pas un
couillon mais il faut il faut le
réveiller convoyer et donc le parcours
professionnel est un parcours de reprise
de confiance qui se fait dans le kit
très développé dans d'autres pays que le
nôtre en suisse en allemagne par exemple
c'est commun nous c'est le parcours des
chèques alors que ça doit être un
parcours d'un nouvel éveil alors
effectivement vous allez finalement vous
tourner vers messi qui va effectivement
vous amener à l'exploration et j'ai lu
que vous et connaître le degré de
résistance du corps humain dans des
conditions extrêmes quarante ans après
vous en savez plus sur le degré de
résistance du corps humain la déconnade
et capacité d'adaptation d'une
maniabilité si vous voulez à la
situation situation physiologie d'abord
vous voyez quand on monte en altitude la
pression de l'oxygène se raréfie et donc
quand on fait de l'alpinisme haute
altitude on a le corps qui s'adaptent à
cette baisse de pression une multitude
de petites choses qui se dotent de
manière à pouvoir bénéficier de cette
chute de pression pour alimenter le
corps et au froid c'est pareil mais ça
je l' ai découvert voyez je suis resté
63 jours au froid en allant au fond
norbi températures négatives de - 52 ans
-18 points
la température de mon corps à l'arrivée
était à 35 5 voyez le locaux il peut
terminer on est en hypothermie et la non
et non on est on est assis si on me met
aujourd'hui ou si on nous met à lire
aujourd'hui à 35 c honnête en
hypothermie mais sur deux mois le corps
avait fait des adaptations de manière à
il est intelligent le corps au lieu de
demander de la nourriture je comprends
rien pour rester à 37 c cho 37 vous
savez on le sait très chaud et pour
rester à 37 ça demande beaucoup
d'alimentation se couvrir dans le corps
il a eu cette intelligence de baisser le
thermostat et 35,5 c'est une économie
d'énergie considérable voyez donc on a
des capacités d'adaptation alors là
c'est la vision du médecin et
l'exploration pourquoi vous y venez
est-ce que adolescent vous rêviez et
parce qu'il y avait des explorateurs qui
vous ai rêvé est ce que quelqu'un vous a
donné envie
pas là pendant la famille non mais je
suis né dans un village j'habitais dans
un village de 800 habitants derrière
chez nous il y avait les champs voyez
donc je vivais dehors j'ai aimé vivre
dehors j'ai aimé la nature j'étais très
timide et la nature était un refuge pour
moi dans lequel je trouver de quoi
satisfaire ma curiosité voyez un peu un
peu intrépide aussi parce que pour
monter chercher lépi au mois de mai par
là quand elle commença avant qu'elle
s'envole du nid j'avais des zozos
apprivoiser voyez je vivais beaucoup
avec la nature et à 14 ans j'avais fait
une liste de matériels pour aller camper
dans les pyrénées en hiver à 14 ans je
me dis moi avec maintenant je me dis
qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans la
tenniswomen de 14 ans en hiver et seul
voyez c'était on se pose la question je
vais l'écrire de gavarnie c'est un
village qui dans les pyrénées il m'avait
répondu en disant d'abord fait un métier
puis revenez me voir quoi donc la notion
d'expédition me plaisait depuis depuis
depuis tout tenir et des explorateurs
qui vous faisait rêver paris les
montagnards c'était surtout les
montagnards walter bonatti lionel terray
ce sont des anciens alpinistes qui m'ont
vraiment vraiment fait rêver je me
projetais dans ça et donc fait des
études de médecine après je passais en
interne en chirurgie j'étais interne en
chirurgie à l'orthopédie on y viendra
et tout d'un coup je me suis mais c'est
peut-être le moment de de proposer mes
services de médecins envoyés préfère des
expéditions j'en avais tellement rêvé
petit je dis je veux faire une
parenthèse et c'est comme ça que j'ai
proposé mes services de médecins à eric
tabarly newey la coupe charles 11 ans
eric tabarly
ah oui eric tabarly gelé rencontré à
l'aéroport à rio je rentrais dfx royce
et une montagne magnifique en patagonie
et lui il était là en escale d'une
course d'une course au large je me suis
approché de lui dit si vous chercher
mais d'abord et il m'a regardé comme ça
éric ils étaient tels tout le monde
voulait embarquer avec eric tabarly donc
il se protégeait un peu des
sollicitations ils me regardent vous
êtes un non non je suis pas de la course
une alpiniste à bord le pin donc ça
l'intéressé j'ai pu discuter avec lui je
suis médecin si vous voulez un médecin
pour la prochaine course autour du monde
ça me feuilles je suis sportif je peux
rendre service et julien envoyé un petit
mot non je vais donner mon adresse il
m'a envoyé une lettre que j'ai toujours
et vous appris des choses eric tabarly
eric tabarly c'était quelqu'un qui
dirigeait par le silence il a ils
étaient indiscutables dans sa décision
voyez moi j'étais mon chef de gare c'est
philippe poupon en grand marin et donc
chili pas les voir philou aller voir
eric en dix ans a fraîchi fodé peut-être
et ribemont t il regarder puis disait
quelque chose que celui qui était
pendant un riz par exemple c'était pas
du style on parie tout le monde l'achète
ou l'envoyer c'était d'apprendre et donc
celui qu'il avait entendu gala tout le
monde dont paris et eric était présent
comme ça dans le silence non c'était
et en plus une tolérance parce que lui
il avait 47 ans et l'équipage avait 24
ans de moyenne d'âge way se répète ses
enfants il avait une tolérance par
rapport à 7 et aujourd'hui vous
embarquerez avec qui est ce que un
explorateur vous fait rêver ce qu' il y
en a un qui vous vient alors ça c'est
pas du tout la même chose mais je pense
en vous posant la question à thomas
pesquet par exemple qui est devenu celui
qui fait rêver c'est une autre forme
d'exploration c'est l'exploration de
l'espace oui mais j'avais posé ma
candidature en 1983 donc j'ai même les
résultats j'avais été dans la première
série d'admissibles et il m'a manqué une
chose c'était d'avoir fait une
publication scientifique
moi j'avais donc que je comme je voulais
dire c'est appeler de tourneur fraiseur
emmanuel mois et donc j'expliquais dans
la lettre de motivation qu'il fallait
mieux là où un bon bricoleur si vous
voulez qu'un cerveau qui avaient des
cafés des communications scientifiques
savaient peut-être plus je ne sais pas
mais ça m'aurait plu effectivement mais
aujourd'hui je suis capable
de fait renvoyé dans l'espace social et
qui vous fait rêver tout haut mais ce
calepin oui bien sûr j'aurais aimé c'est
pas thomas pesquet qui me fait rêver
c'est d'être dans la station spatiale
qui m'aurait plu nous voir la terre de
là haut alors des fois je me couche je
me console je me dis bon ils sont quand
même 400 km c'est pas très loin mais je
trouve ça formidable la technologie est
intéressant dans ses expéditions vous
rendez compte tout de suite que c'est
fait pour vous que vous allez y
consacrer toute votre vie ou pas un
certain moment donc j'ai fait pendant 12
ans des expéditions voyez le dôme des
grandes écuries malaya face nord de
l'everest à bari et c'est beaucoup et
j'étais à la face nord de l'everest
météo quand deux des médecins il y avait
3 3 qui était en difficulté à 8000
mètres d'altitude donc j'étais monté
aucun d'eux je t'ai seule la sur une
arête à l'abri des avalanches s'étaient
bien et en main dole et je me dis mais
maintenant je vais avoir 40 ans bientôt
il faut que je fasse la mienne
mon expédition pour clôturer cette vie
d' aventure et ça a été le pôle nord au
nord en solitaire que j'ai fait et ça a
été extrêmement structurants pour moi
j'ai résisté aux tentations de l'abandon
quasi tout le temps au début parce que
cette bulle - vous avez failli mourir
vous êtes senti en danger certainement
oui puis de la chance mais sur plusieurs
expéditions j'ai tout oui plusieurs fois
que j'ai eu de la chance et avalanches
en himalaya ou un sort juste avant la
coulée qui descend sur vous
au pôle nord passé sur une glace très
fine et là si vous passez à l'eau à
travers une glace fine êtes sûr de pas
pouvoir remonter j'ai eu des frayeurs
comme ça mais ce qui m'a structure est
donc comme je vous le dis jamais il y
avait pas de gps pas de téléphone donc
c'est une immersion dans son rêve est
dans le rêve il est fragile quand on est
confronté à des conditions aussi
difficiles elle à l isolement et donc
j'ai tenu j'ai résisté à la tentation de
l'abandon qui me qu'était tout le temps
parce que je peux progresser lentement
et en fait j'ai il m'a fallu un mois
pour
oublier je dirais être à la pesanteur du
monde vous voyez être dans mon histoire
et je suis arrivé au pôle nord ya rien
au pôle nord c'est rencontre au milieu
d'un milieu de l'océan voyez parce que
là banquise bouge sans arrêt et là je me
suis dit tu t'es tellement libéré
tellement heureux libéré de quoi de ce
projet qui me qui m'avait attiré j'ai
échoué en 85 gérer shoots réussis en 86
donc je sais je le sentiment que ma vie
devait passer à travers le pôle nord et
donc je me suis dit mais ça ça va être
ma vie voyez j'étais revenu costaud sur
cette capacité que j'allais avec les
autres en expédition et là je me dis
mais je suis capable de monter des
expéditions ça a été un départ vous êtes
aussi l'un des premiers à faire de la
pédagogie sur les régions polaires
aujourd'hui ça prend encore plus de sens
vous avez été parmi les premiers à
expliquer à quel point elles ont de
l'importance pour la vie sur terre pour
la planète pour le climat est-ce que
vous avez le sentiment parfois de ne pas
avoir été entendu
non je pense que j'ai été entendu mais
pour parler d'une haute d'une chose qui
est le réchauffement climatique c'est
énorme voyez ce que je veux dire et pour
arriver à inculquer que c'est une
réalité on a perdu beaucoup de temps
avec le réchauffement climatique parce
qu'on en a fait un sujet de conversation
populaire du style deux personnes vont
le matin chez boulanger il est mode
juillet par exemple acheter la baguette
de pain il fait froid ce matin là dans
l'autre il va dire il ya un kilo
petit-croix toi t'as vu comment se calme
au dessus et lotryl valeo est très
présent il nous raconte des trucs ça ne
se perçoit pas la planète s'est
réchauffée de 1 degrés en un siècle
personne ne peut percevoir ce
réchauffement moyen et ses sept chefs
chronique qui est là qui s'installe
depuis un moment et donc qu'est ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire que ça ne se
transforme pas les musées dont on parle
aujourd'hui elle aurait été bénéfique il
ya vingt ans quand on était sûr que
l'homme voyez rien
mais éminent glaciologue qui s'appelle
claude lorius qu'avec qui a travaillé
avec jean jouzel notre glaciologue sur
les carottes de glace en antarctique qui
nous racontent l'histoire du climat de
la terre sur aujourd'hui à peu près un
million d'années et j'avais fait une
conférence avec claude lorius 190 moi je
rentrais de l'antarctique je parlais de
mes chiens la traversée et lui claude
nous parlent de ce qu'ils trouvaient
dans les carottes et nous montre fait ça
la courbe qui fait ça voyez période
interglaciaire glaciaires et
interglaciaires donc la perte à terre là
sa vie propre mais là il dit regardez
depuis 150 ans cette accélération de la
température et de la teneur en gaz
carbonique elle est là la signature
l'activité humaine c'était en 90 et donc
si tout d'un coup on avait pris la
mesure voyez ce que je veux dire c'est
là qu'on a perdu la mesure ça passe par
des conversations entre france est aussi
français est ce que certains aient des
doutes non mais français et planétaire
parce que on est un des acteurs même que
dire des petits acteurs le problème
c'est le charbon qui est l'ennemi numéro
un du climat parce que le charbon a même
quantité d'énergie produite par rapport
au gaz par exemple s'il exploités dans
des bonnes conditions il sait la moitié
de co2 et donc déjà si cette transition
se faisait faire usage du gaz dans une
transition s'assurait mai mais remue le
monde sur cette question qui est
l'énergie l'énergie c'est quelque chose
qui nous fait vivre on s'en rend pas
compte on branche une prison c'est parce
que ça consomme on va faire le plein
d'essence parce que il faut les soigner
ce que je veux dire c'est tellement
facile et en main donné on parle de
restreint de l'énergie transformée de
nos ressources énergétiques
donc ça c'est une inertie colossal
qu'est ce qui concrètement vous vous a
frappé lors de vos expéditions vous ai
dit la planète est en train de se
réchauffer concret qui pourrait parler à
noter gt2 chose bon les régions polaires
sont des régions qui nous révèle comme
je viens de le dire l'histoire du climat
et en même temps ce sont des témoins
aujourd'hui au réchauffement quitte à
l'oeuvre
le pôle nord est omis de l'océan gelé
donc en 86 bien sûr je rencontre des
ouvertures dans la glace mais peu
importe c'est normal parce que la glace
bouge j'ai survolé en ballon en 2010 en
avril début avril début avril 2010 c'est
la fin de l'hiver en ballon qu'est ce
que je constate à 2000 mètres d'altitude
est immense déjà étendue d'eau libre
alors que c'est le sait à peine la fin
de l'hiver ça c au nord et au sud j'ai
traversé l'antarctique en équipe
internationale avait avec des traîneaux
à chiens et les 600 premiers kilomètres
on était sur la péninsule antarctique
est un appendice on était sur ce qu'on
appelle des plateformes de glace des
glaciers descendent flotte sur la mer et
donc on est passés les 600 premiers
kilomètres ont disparu se sont détachés
du voyez donc on pourrait plus refaire
aujourd'hui l'expédition l'intégralité
de l'expédition que j'ai fait en temps
89 donc s'il y a il ya une accélération
effectivement lab de la prégnance du
réchauffement climatique sur la planète
et on le voit quoi est-ce que vous
restez tout de même optimiste est ce que
vous avez
fois en l'innovation
par l'homme en sa capacité à eux on a
aujourd'hui la conscience de la
situation la personne je crois qu'ils
disent que non c'est très clair c'est
très clair ona l'intelligence des
solutions les solutions elles sont de
deux ordres des leçons comportementale
on le sait ce qu'il faut économiser
l'énergie et s'est fait pas faire la
liste de tout ce que l'on doit faire
pour économiser l'énergie limiter les
émissions de gaz cavale et donc elles
sont comportementale et chacun d'entre
nous doit être efficace sur sa zone d
influence on a tous une zone d'
influence dans sa vie personnelle
familiale professionnelle politique vous
voyez ce que je veux dire là il faut
être au maximum de ce que l'on peut
faire dans son action donc ça c'est la
réponse comportementale et puis à une
réponse technologique il est évident
qu'aujourd'hui quand on trouve un moteur
par exemple ils vont être banni les
moteurs thermiques mais quand on fait un
moteur à explosion qui consomme 2 litres
au cent par rapport à 25 litres dia
longtemps voyez donc ce la technologie
va nous offrir effectivement lusage de
l'électricité pour les voitures et
cetera donc les technologies qu'on a
besoin d'ingénieurs on a besoin
d'ingénieurs pour inventer le futur quoi
est-ce que c'est aussi un peu le sens de
votre prochaine aventure parce qu'il y
en a une autre c'est pas du tout terminé
les expéditions pour vous vous repartez
à bord du polar pas dans l'antarctique
explique et non alors là c'est
l'antarctique c'est le camp l'arctique
en eau l'antarctique c'est en bas
l'article dont je parle tout à l'heure
est un immense océan entouré de terres
l'antarctique c'est un continent qui est
grand comme 28 pour la france voyait un
puzzle comme ça de 28 france et la
taille de l'antarctique et tout autour
il ya le l'océan austral et cet océan il
est loin il est difficile d'accès il y à
quelques missions qui se sont rares les
français à fond avec le marion dufresne
qui est un navire qui va de la réunion à
kerguelen mais ces explorations elles se
font essentiellement l'été donc toutes
les publications se termine on a besoin
de mesures in situ de longue durée ça
veut dire on a besoin s'installer sur
cet océan et cet océan c'est celui que
nous font découvrir tous les marins du
vendée globe tous les quatre ans les
fameuses 50e hurlants voyez donc c'est
le principal puits de carbone océanique
de la planète on en est quasi certain
quel est son efficacité on ne le sait
pas et donc l'équation qui m'a intéressé
quel type de bateau de vaisseau on peut
inventer on peut construire pour
séjourner dans les 50e hurlants dans des
bonnes conditions c'est fou un pardon
j'y reviens mais peut-être l'idée l'idée
est décalé un peu convoyer parce que
l'idée naturel fait on va faire un liban
en bateau mais ça va pas en bateau un
bateau vous est posée sur la mer vous
êtes sans arrêt agité surtout dans ce
coin et l'idée que j'ai travaillé avec
un bureau d'études qui est à lorient
aussi pester en fait l'idée simple c'est
d'avoir un bateau c'est faire un bateau
verticale c'est à dire que il est ancré
dans 80 mètres de profondeur donc le
vent agite la surface un bateau il est
posé sur la surface les bouge mais si
vous avez un tube c'est un tube on
n'habite pas de sous un tube qui descend
avec 150 tonnes de lest au fond vous
êtes pris dans des eaux stable et déjà
donc vous êtes échapper à la surface et
à la surface à la mine treillis c'est à
dire que les vagues nous passe à travers
donc il est très confortable on avait
fait alors il faut vous avez raison de
ces fous mais les ingénieurs aujourd'hui
et je mènerai découvre des start up de
l'intelligence incroyable on a fait des
maquettes on les a on a simulé les 50e
hurlants dans le bassin à vagues
l'ifremer ou à l'école centrale de
nantes et on sait aujourd'hui que c'est
beaucoup plus stable qu'un navire et ce
qui est donc pour vivre longtemps si
loin il fallait qu'il soit autonome et
donc le moteur c'est le courant il n'a
pas de moteur le moteur c'est le courant
qui va nous entraîner autour de
l'antarctique et l'électricité c'est le
vent passe y en a beaucoup et vous fixé
aucune limite même pas d'âge sur cette
exploration vous tester un peu vos
limites à vous aussi qu'est ce que vous
me dites voulez que je vous dise je suis
jeune depuis plus longtemps que vous
avant
jean louis etienne on a un rituel dans
cette émission on a même plusieurs
d'ailleurs vous allez le découvrir mais
on n'en notamment un qu'on a appelé la
séquence photo je vais vous montrer
quelques photos alors on a d'abord pensé
à celles ci pour vous vous êtes aux
côtés d'autres explorateurs et notamment
si je ne me trompe pas dites moi de will
stieger c'est bien ça willsie gaza c'est
l'américain effectivement avec l'iran
dont incroyable improbables je crois
mais j'ai rencontré willy au pôle nord
un soir j'entendais des bruits comme ça
je dis merde ça nours et puis non
c'était les chiens de l'expédition oui
stieger aidant s'est mis d'accord pour
faire une expédition en antarctique
c'était en 89 il fallait être il fallait
être un acteur de la reconduction du
traité de l'antarctique et donc jeudi
pour une expédition internationale et on
a vu une baseline d'antarctique n'est
pas un continent pour les hommes c'est
un continent pour la terre et donc on a
réuni donc un japonais en russe qui
était soviétique quand on est partis
encore un chinois de chine populaire et
puis donc magnifique expédition wii sega
votre beau chant jeux wii que je
m'adresse ici pour lire vous avez il y
avait en plus de l'anglais alors on a
pensé à une autre photo pour vous qui va
peut-être surprendre nos téléspectateurs
mais pas vous j'en suis certaine c'est
un bloc opératoire vous l'avez dit vous
avez été interne en chirurgie et là sur
cette photo précisément vous avez 25 ans
et vous assistez le docteur dit le chef
de service en service ou et à castres
oui mais bon souvenir la chirurgie
extraordinaire s'est massé ma
frustration parce que j' ai adoré ça le
docteur guy b donc été chef de service
je lui demande j'étais en deuxième année
de médecine je lui demande si je peux
regarder avait assisté aux opérations il
me dit venaient tous les matins j'étais
là un jour urgence de la main
l'inter n'est pas là il est dans le
service et le guide et se retourne vers
la chef du bloc madame assad j'ai des
noms comme ça il n'oublia habib etienne
un chirurgien vous habillez vous voyez
vous vous ne mettrez à billets et là
tout d'un coup je met les mains dans la
médecine voyez c'est un coup de foudre
kelly mais je serai chez le chien est
donc j'étais interne en chirurgie avec
une passion pour l'orthopédie
l'orthopédie c'est la charpente royer
c'est l'articulation c'est la mobilité
je mets des clous des plaques proches
j'étais moi je vais me dire que j'avais
un ca paie déjà voyez ce que je veux
dire jamais une forme un signalement
c'est cohérent sur c'était très cohérent
mais donc j'ai
aimé passionnément la chirurgie et comme
je vous disais ça reste une frustration
mais on peut pas tout faire s'il y avait
des choses à refaire
ce schéma m'a conduit vers les
expéditions que j'avais envie c'est
parce que j'étais
médecin chirurgien que j'ai pu être
admis dans des grandes expéditions et
s'ils avaient des choses à refaire il ya
des choses que vous referiez
différemment aujourd'hui non mais pas de
regrets vous n'avez aucune heure il y
avait les quelques frustrations de quand
je viens d'évoquer une autre frustration
j'étais demi de mêlée au castres
olympique
ingénieur belge ignora j'ai eu un
problème de santé qui m'a interdit
j'étais malheureux mais malheureux
pourquoi c'est important aujourd'hui
j'étais un garçon extrêmement timide et
tout d'un coup le rugby faisait que je
ne rougis sait plus quand on mène voyez
quand ont interpellé dans un groupe
comme ça j'avais trouvé ma place j'étais
demi-de-mêlée j'ai adoré ce sport est un
accident de santé a fait que j'ai dû
abandonner autre séquence la séquence
archives puisque les archives nationales
nous font le plaisir on propose chaque
semaine un document qui peut avoir du
sens pour notre invité et on a pensé à
celui ci pour vous alors je vais vous le
donner en mains propres alors vous vous
devez mettre vos lunettes peut-être pour
rien le bleu clair mais moi je les
traduis régime et le traduire pour nos
pour nos téléspectateurs ces actes de
propriété d'une partie des terres
australes par la france s'agit d'un
courrier adressé en 1849 au ministre de
la marine qui je cite par sa lettre du
20 juin 1843 l'amiral base au chalet
rendu compte au département de la marine
de l'arrêt et qu'il avait pris pour
ordonner la prise de possession au nom
de la france des îles saint paul et
amsterdam voleurs on a eu raison de
penser à ce document pour vous oui alors
saint paul et amsterdam ça fait partie
effectivement d'un patrimoine français
qui est reconnu la france possède une
partie de cet argent là les gens se
parlent et antarctiques françaises et
donc qu'elle possède de marion crozet
kerguelen amsterdam ce sont ces îles la
des terres australes et revendique une
autre qui s'appelle la terre adélie la
terre adélie c'était un peu à cette
période là quand dumont d'urville prend
possession de la terre adélie l'appel
terre adélie pas sa femme s'appelait
adel comme il appellera délit c'est un
morceau de camembert voiliers de
l'antarctique en partant du pôle sud ce
n'est qu'une revendication territoriale
qui n'est pas reconnue par aucun traité
onusien il ya sept pays qui revendique
et ça c'est une revendication
territoriale non reconnue par la
communauté scientifique passer des
haltères le fait que la france possède
ses terres s'adonnent à la france une
responsabilité particulière sur wii ça
donne une responsabilité particulière
d'ailleurs ça donne des facilités
technologiques des centres d'écouté dans
le secteur et ça donne effectivement
l'opportunité de qui se développe
beaucoup aujourd'hui d'avoir des
réserves territoriale de biodiversité et
la france en même temps un beyens et
herlin les surveille les surveille de la
surpêche
c'est très très loin de tout voyez en
poissons qu'on appelle le régime qui a
une haute valeur commerciale et s'il n'y
avait personne pour surveiller ça elle
serait payée totalement et donc la
france protège cmc ces terres là parce
qu'elles possèdent et on a ce qu'on
appelle la zone économique exclusive qui
est 200 milles nautiques autour de
chacune des possessions et la france
surveille ça et heureusement des terres
qu'il faudrait 100 tu arrives il y en a
une qui est sanctuarisé qui s'appelle
creuser est une qui est un une aire une
aire marine protégée dans laquelle on ne
peut absolument pas y aller elle est
dernière séquence cette fois c'est
vraiment la dernière de l'émission je
vous le promets sur lui c'est le choix
de la vertu je vous reprends le document
merci beaucoup nous sommes entourés vous
l'aurez remarqué dans cette tour de
l'horloge au sénat qui est donc un lieu
assez méconnu de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu vous avez
la sagesse oui derrière vous la prudence
oui la justice et l'éloquence est ce que
il y en a une qui vous parlent plus
qu'ils ont tout à fait d'accord avec ces
trois là un
la prudence
n'est pas dire qu'il est prudent sinon
je suis formé il ya souvent une chanson
de brel qui me revient le monde se
meurent par manque d'imprudence voiliers
et je trouve que il faut faire la place
à l'ambition aux et voiliers aux essais
engagé son imagination ou delà des
certitudes et donc on entre dans un dans
un secteur si vous voulez ou des fois on
est bridée par la norme où il ya ce que
je veux dire oui et pour moi la norme
c'est bon et la norme existe il faut
qu'elles existent si vous voulez mais
aux essais passer la frontière vous
amène experts l'expert il est garant de
la norme et quand vous créez quelque
chose vous êtes au delà de la norme et
cette part d'imprudence qui peut être
lieu de créativité et c'est un
magnifique message pour conclure cette
émission merci infiniment jean louis
lamarre était notre invité dans un monde
un regard merci nous avoir donné un
petit peu de votre monde et de votre
regard c'est la fin de cette émission à
très bientôt sur public sénat
[Musique]